if you forged the sword and now you've
become almost known as like the comedian
destroys heckler guy and you're but it's
not without savvy strategy behind it and
you seem to be tapped into you've always
been a forward thinker at 18 you create
your own sports website you were a lot
of people get Dane Cook credit on
MySpace but you were actually in the
myspace game as well I I was although
you know Dane was bigger than I was for
sure I've always tried to figure out
what is the next thing nice and you know
five years ago I was telling every comic
get on reddit get on reddit get on
reddit and most of them didn't listen to
me and my video going number one I read
it is what
that's what popped mmm and so there's
and there's a lot of things that you
always look for what's next and you
don't know it till you find it and
sometimes you'll be wrong the heckler
stuff I never tried for that to be a
thing
it happened organically I would just
post videos to YouTube because I wanted
to post stuff that wasn't my set I
wanted to post outtakes or material I
stopped doing right right but I didn't
want to post stuff I was doing currently
and so a lot of those outtakes were
heckler stuff because that's what wasn't
supposed to be in the set right and but
what I did notice I noticed it started
touching a nerve and that's when I
started leaning into it now I'm fully
aware that being known for dealing with
hecklers is not the only thing you want
to be known for but I see it as a
gateway to my comedy for sure it is when
that heckler video popped the video ID
posted just before was a self-produced
special and so three million people came
and watched that video in three days and
then another half a million of them
stayed and watched the special and
that's how I started I went from at the
time I had 95 thousand subscribers now I
have over half a million mm-hmm and it
was because I had other content on there
so you know the heckler stuff I I like
that it's done well I don't regret that
it's done well at all a lot of times
people who try to make fun of it are
actually doing it inaccurately will it
be like community into stories how to
learn a bunch of capital letters and
exclamation points and I'm like
I've never had a video with with
anything like that oh and I wasn't
saying you know no I know I know you're
not I I'm saying that like it's funny to
me that the idea of people using
clickbait titles people using all caps
people use an exclamation points I've
never done that it's the people who have
tried to copy what I've done who have
gone too far and then I get made fun of
for that and a because the people who
make fun of that stuff are lazy and if
anybody's watching and you know I've had
people tell me the heckler thing is a
gimmick and it's funny because one of
the people who told me that literally
perform santim comedy in a bear costume
in a laundromat the heckler thing isn't
a gimmick or just part of what we do
mm-hm
it's that would be like saying that slam
dunking is a gimmick instead of you know
oh you you just got to shoot threes and
it's like no that's one part of your
game exactly but part of the game for
any sand of comic is being able to add
lip and I'm a better ad lib er than I am
a writer and I'm certainly and I'm a
better writer than I am an actor so I
you know I have to lean into what I'm
good at
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath reverse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips